Đói đá phục biết là, cái thời gái, nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ đi về lyd sách thức,
nếu cũng tình dùng tất thức thời gái, có khi chúng ta để đối dịch với sách thức.
Bằng cái sức mạnh của Toan Jan, lúc đó không chỉ là Việt mắt nó,
Việt mắt là cảm, cái vùng cân cứ đều kích mạnh.
Đất là mạnh, nhưng mà cả chúng kì ở Nam kì.
Tế lúc thấy thì hình cũng đá có chỉ bịn chuyện.
Còn lời chúng ta vẫn đặc biệt là ta, là lấy đào được các cộng chúc của chúng.
Cái cả cái đức lành bích lịch.
Nếu chỉ một phật nằm đó,
tình là tâm tà mê lù, cái điều kên, là chúng ta khi mà,
có khi là cái kì thế là, là cái kì thế, là ra phật,
nó và hình đặc biệt ta.
Thì lúc đó là chúng ta trất biệt lời.
Gốc trên đại hồi chúng ta, và ra cái kì kì kì kì kì kì kì kì kì kì,
nó tâm tà gế, cái như vậy là dụt tà.
Chần vì được cả hốn thử.
Cà lực glần của chúng ta, cái kì kì kì kì kì, kì bồ mấy.
Để rực khi về hôn hội, là chúng ta đã cóng đi bồ mấy đệ lánh đặc biệt nào.
Ở, cái trụ đốt đánh nhớ.
Dên lên là cái hơi cơ.
Tòi như là, để lấy hơi cơ mà, đàn cá, và bật hồn.
Đả dần chúng có khác hết sức là cái kì kì kì kì kì kì.
Nếu sợn hơn, cũng không đờ.
Nhưng mà nhau đến tế đi thì cũng khúc chắc
và khó khăn hư
nên tôi nghĩ là đây là cái thời gian trên bà
có thể qua là ngạch nắm có vợ
Thôi giờ đến một cái cộng đơ
ở trong đây học lịch cơ của chúng mình
có bạch nữ thái xe lên bỏ khi
rộng thời bộc cộng thành công
Thưa có tất nhiên để chiến mình tham
trả chúng ta nói một cộng về cái việc nắm khóc và thích chục tới vô
Hãy subscribe và like và like và like và subscribe.